I'd rather have three people that buy my
[ __ ] that happened three people let's
see my [ __ ] and buy it that have a
hundred people similar [ __ ]
and one person buys it right and we're
just way too caught
here's rheumatic all the herbs in New
York have come into business world right
the screen of the back cocaine which is
bright I'm a fan of the math there
especially cuz it's usually the partner
in crime I need to do my damage the
problem with that is is we've gotten too
heavy
at some level on just metrics and data
and things that nature of war the math
is right it's just we have to be looking
at the right math and people are just
very caught up in a lot of perception is
reality or just me there's a there's an
overestimation right now reaches value
in the marketplace and that's it i mean
i sitter will never act forward to
personal agency and it blows my mind
that eighty of my clients cared more
about you know awareness and how many
people they reach them actually selling
you a cup of coffee or they're like
there is some separation in the market
makes more now than ten fifteen years
ago in business these metrics versus
what we were here to do which was to
sell mountain Dew
which was to get people to buy I think
there's a disconnection for me you know
Steve Rogers who's videotaping me right
now I started a news show recently
called askgaryvee back to my earlier
point which is I'm trying to figure out
reset the light value so everyday people
ask me a ton of questions on Twitter I
take five or six of them I take ignite
minutes show right and that's what I do
and so I want to provide value I like it
well now we've got a got you if you pump
the planets around the show I get an
exposure to get a couple followers it's
just providing it for a value we give
them a phone YouTube it gets too long
the intros too long this event and it's
all about the optimization without any
conversation around the heart which is
people I care about
II do want nine minutes I'm not going to
be just you know retro kind of cool like
you know pending videos that like 13
year old girls we were like I'm talking
about that deep business stuff and so
that that I gotta do this I've got
denied they want me to be two questions
well you know if people are care about
me or the people that are in business
won't take 40 questions by good they'll
sit through it so you got to make those
decisions about optimization versus what
is the goal that you're trying to
achieve it in that world sure there's my
Eagle what will you use for video
absolutely I've got a big [ __ ] box
I'll date the 43,000 that actually
really care about that or more likely to
buy my book whatever this book comes out
or more likely to come to or do what or
become an employee by rolling the things
that I actually business care about